okay so task master is a big character
in the marvel universe
known as one of the best hand-to-hand
fighters in the comics
anthony masters is able to duke it out
with pretty much any member of the
avengers
over the years he's featured in a number
of stories games
and animated shows and the character has
been instrumental in training people
like us
agent he's pretty much the guy your girl
tells you not to worry about
and because of this he's gained a big
following over the years
for better or worse the film black widow
decided to massively divert from this
in order to change a lot of things about
the core character of taskmaster
and yeah it's went down worse than matt
hancock giving out social distancing
guidelines
coming away from the movie it's clear
that the reveal is probably the most
controversial point and taskmaster right
now is pretty much the marmite of the
mcu
jeremy johns said they were the worst
mcu villain ever
my grandma said they were the best and
even after carrying out polls on twitter
it's clear everyone's opinion is very
split now personally i don't like the
betrayal
but i know a lot of you do so if that's
the case then i'm i'm glad you enjoyed
them
i'm not someone who hates women or even
gender swapping and in the case of flag
smasher and falcon in the winter soldier
i feel that when it's done in service of
the plot that it can really work
black smasher was someone who was meant
to juxtapose the might of the us
military
and this low-key small and humble girl
very much helped to paint out a normal
person who was put in an extreme
situation
which i think vastly aided her betrayal
for me taskmaster is quite the opposite
and throughout this video i'm going to
be going over why the character
just didn't work in my opinion now there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to check out the
movie yet then i highly recommend that
you check out now
i want to see what the general feelings
are towards this so if you don't like
the reveal then please click the thumbs
up button
and the thumbs downs there if you do
without the way i hope you enjoy the
video
now let's get into why i think
taskmaster sucked
okay so in the film we learn the
taskmaster is actually drakov's daughter
antonia
in the movie we discovered that the
infamous budapest mission involved
natasha attempting to assassinate the
villain
and she was caught in the crosshairs
because nat was so desperate to murder
him that she was happy to sacrifice a
child to do it
it's one of the darkest if not the
darkest character decisions in the
entire mcu
carried out by a hero now though thanos
was happy to wipe out half of all life
in the universe
he did it completely detached from
everything whereas nat
actually had to give the order knowing
full well who and what would die
it seemed like the mcu had finally
painted her out as the complex person
that she really was
but they pull their punches and show
that she survived it so
nat really wasn't that bad looking back
even though she was willing to say
them kids instead the life of torture
that she was subjected to
is very much put on drakov as he was the
one that twisted her
into a brainless and mind-controlled
assassin i feel this is a cop-out
and it slightly lessens the impact of
the biggest mistake natasha ever made
meaning that she can now sleep well at
night now the next part that i feel
doesn't work
is the costume design i was on twitter
yesterday and someone said that
taskmaster looks like a beetle borg
and i can't unsee it you already know
that taskmaster's costume was changed up
massively so that the movie could be
marketed to chinese audiences
but my issues go far beyond that
taskmaster is part of the red room
a program that twists and transforms
women into cold-blooded killers
they clearly don't mind women being at
the front and center and don't bother to
disguise what they look like or even
hide their faces
therefore i just can't understand the
logic behind why taskmaster looks like a
dude
there is absolutely no reason why they
would make her appear as a man
and having a costume that isn't really
designed for antonia's body
surely would make it more difficult for
her to move correctly and carry out
missions
now clearly this is done because in the
comics taskmaster is a man
and it's meant to throw us off the scene
so that when the reveal happens
it's a big shock if you're 5 years old
now it's very meta that they chose to do
this and when you think about it
there's no reason why the characters in
the movie would ever think to make
antonia appear as a man
unless they're aware that people are
watching and want a surprise
unless drakov is sitting there thinking
i want people to think this is rick
mason
then yeah no reason for it to be in the
film at all
i've asked a lot of people why they
think that taskmaster is made to look
this way
and no one can give me an answer that
actually makes sense beyond
that sort of how he looks in the comics
people have said that the suit could be
keeping her alive and helping her to
live
but this has been designed by drakov a
man who has a flying fortress
so you'd think that after all these
years he'd come up with something else
to make it so that she could live and
fight comfortably
just makes absolutely no sense when you
look at things from the character's
point of view
and clearly the only reason that it
happened like this was to give the
audience a shock
it's putting a twist above what actually
makes sense and for me it's one of the
biggest flaws in the entire
movie as logically it doesn't stack up
grace randolph even came up with a
suggestion that i think would have
worked really well
and had dracov said something like i
always wanted a son
it would have worked much better also
yeah how good is that draco impressions
really really good i swear now instead
what we have is a group of female
assassins
where for some reason one is made to
look like a man
because reasons also that unmasking
scene looks really really bad
when we pull away and see olga's tiny
head superimposed onto a bodybuilder
i don't know why they kept that shot in
the movie as it looks like she did a
full body workout
and skipped head day this is really bad
and considering the mcu is normally the
benchmark for things like the aging and
special effects
it just makes the reveal laughable when
what we should be focusing on is how
painful this is for the character
now the next issue i have is that they
nerfed the power set the taskmaster has
and instead of it being her abilities
that pushed her to the forefront of the
red room
it's a computer program that does all
the work one of my big issues with the
film
is the whole mind controlled subplot as
i think when characters make their own
choices
that's far more interesting nat had just
gone on the run from the government
and i really wish that that was the
thing that inspired her sister to leave
the red room
rather than some magical myths that
completely erases all the programming
that she'd been subjected to for it's
the same in the case of taskmaster
and i think it would have been far more
interesting if she was someone who lived
in the shadow of elena and wanted to
impress her father because the former
was the favorite instead of her
though she had spent years copying
mimicking the best fighters on earth
just to live up to what he wanted her to
be however all that she saw when she
looked in the mirror
was a broken disfigured woman that he
would never love and thus her breaking
free of his control
i feel would have been a much stronger
character moment instead though it's
just a computer doing all the work
analyzing fight patterns and making her
carry them out
she's a machine at the end of the day
and that's just not interesting to
follow as a villain in my opinion
and that kind of ties into my last point
which is that olga kurolenko
is criminally underused even though she
hasn't appeared in any big films for a
while
i think that she's a very recognizable
name and the more positive responses
online that i've seen
involve her coming back into a big
franchise olga is someone who i feel
always had a tough time and quantum of
solace especially is a film that i feel
is very underrated
this could have been her big return to
cinema but instead she just gets two
lines
and stands about staring angrily like
she watched this video before
i made it it leads to the performance
being very underwhelming
and for someone that's been waiting the
best part of two years to see taskmaster
on screen
i feel they've massively missed the mark
to me this isn't even taskmaster
and instead what we get is just the name
slapped onto another character
along with the mimic gimmick so we have
some cool fight scenes
i kind of feel like we might get a
similar situation to the mandarin
where come phase eight kevin feig he'll
come out on stage with someone in that
costume and say
this is the real mandarin guys we know
we're messed up
but but that's where this is the real
one now those are all the reasons that
the character was disappointing for me
and i know a lot of you will disagree
but i've tried to structure this video
so i'm not just bashing it and hopefully
this has helped you to see things from
my point of view
and understand my criticisms if you love
the character then i'm happy for you
and i'd love to see people's thoughts in
the comments below we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three mcu box sets on the 30th of july
and all you have to do to be with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the video
we picked the winners at random at the
end of the month and those who won the
last one are on screen right now
say that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our easter egg breakdown
of the movie which will be linked on
screen right now
we've pointed out all the cool little
details in it so definitely go and give
it a watch especially if you enjoyed the
film
without the way thank you for singing
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace